Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead SwiftRage, PJ Salt and Failfish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning, now he calls me.
This doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a
made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago.